[Music]
my next guest is a talented comedian who
co-hosts the nerd of mouth podcast on
cavecomedyradio.com and he's making his
late night debut with us right here
tonight please welcome the very funny
mike lawrence
[Applause]
[Music]
uh it's great to be here uh i live in
new york which is three hours in the
future
and i hate when people say this when
they go
new york city
eight million people eight million
stories
there's three new york stories all right
there's i moved here i lived here all my
life and ghostbusters
i am excited about jeremy lin i think he
is amazing here's how you know it's an
incredible story there have been more
movies made about dogs playing
basketball
than there have been about asians
playing basketball
i would also like to nominate jeremy lin
as the one celebrity you should not
point out in public
because you will be wrong and racist
i'm not a fan of sports unless we're
talking the huey lewis and the news
album and let's
but what i hate are people who are
morally opposed to sports like i was
talking this guy and he was like i think
football is wrong and it's just cruel
that we cheer on these men who run into
each other and get hurt and i was like
they don't care because they live in
mansions
and he was like yeah man but would you
want to live in a mansion with
alzheimer's and i was like that sounds
like the best way to have alzheimer's
every day you wake up and someone has to
explain to you that it's your mansion
tackle me now
i uh i really miss my grandma guys we
lost her in 2001 and she died in 2006.
and we used to visit her at her
retirement home in south florida
redundant
and the name of her retirement home was
the preserve
because irony ends when social security
begins
and i went there once and someone pulled
the fire alarm and there is nothing more
undramatic than when someone pulls a
fire alarm at an old folks home
the most exciting thing that happened
was an old man just stood up and yelled
let the fire take me
and then he threw a werther's original
at it
i'm not afraid to die i think it'd be
way worse to be immortal because think
about it every 50 or 60 years your wife
dies and you got to get a new one
and each one has more rights than the
last one
hey honey let's go out and vote damn it
woman that used to be my alone time
i used to love playing the game yo mama
when i was a kid
i know the proper pronunciation is yo
mama
but the thing that always bothered me
about it was people never said the
things about my mom that i hated her for
like it was never like ah snap your
mama's so controlling and manipulative
that even when she dies her words will
still haunt you
that was a jew joke by the way
[Applause]
i used to go to my mom's place for
shabbat which is a female robot
that all the jews are just terrified of
for some reason
why can't we use electricity on
saturdays because the shabbats will
attack us
i'm a i'm a child of divorce because
look at me
i had this face when i was 12.
and i hate the way i found out about my
parents divorce what happened was my mom
took me out for ice cream and she sat me
down she said michael i'm leaving your
father i'm going off to marry another
man and i'm pregnant
and that was really messed up
because that should have been three
different trips to get ice cream
that took you two seconds of life that's
taken me 20 years
i will leave you with this the most
beautiful thing i have ever seen in all
of my life
i saw an improv comedy troupe
fail in front of their parents
and it was so
amazing
this one guy in the troop stood up and
said hey man someone give us a
suggestion of a place we should be at
and the dad just stood up and went
law school
now
thank you guys good night
fantastic
fantastic mike lawrence ladies and
gentlemen